titles without the familiar star power
that we've had in recent years
but that's what i call star power and a
huge smile
they put the clock back to 9.5 seconds
[Applause]
50 points 14 rebounds five blocked shots
50 of 105 points nearly half the team's
total
now jeff with 9.5 remaining
a miracle finish would have to obviously
happen for finnish to pull it out
and again they're out of timeouts
that's why you've got to concentrate on
the details
[Applause]
booker turns shoots fires shot won't go
tucker the rebound
and that'll do it it's over
the bucks have done it the long wait has
ended after a half century
the milwaukee bucks are nba champions
once again
foreign
the emotions come pouring out one of the
greatest nights in milwaukee sports
history
ends in a coronation
and the brilliance of the young man from
athens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another crushing finish for devin booker
and the phoenix suns
after a superb season
this extraordinary story of this
extraordinary young man
gives him his nba title the greek freak
is a greek nba champion
guys we've seen a lot of amazing
performances
this ranks as one of the all-time